bienvenidos en el vídeo anterior vimos
que tenemos la función f x que era igual
a x cuadrada
y que la derivada de esta función
la derivada de esta función f prima de x
es igual a 2x
esta pluma está fallando la derivada f
prima de x
efe prima de x igual a 2 por equis y que
el límite
usted está teniendo problemas con esta
pluma disculpen el límite
conforme h se aproxima a cero recordemos
que esto lo podemos escribir como h o
como delta x es una diferencia en el eje
x de fx + h - f x / h es la definición
de la derivada lo que significa que es
la pendiente en cualquier punto de una
curva y esto nos ayuda a encontrar que
la derivada de esta x al cuadrado es 2x
y podemos usar esto para encontrar las
derivadas de otras funciones y quizás lo
hagamos más adelante pero mientras les
comento que si tenemos el fx igual a x
al cubo su derivada va a ser f prima de
x igual a 3 x
x al cuadrado
si f x fuera igual a x a la cuarta
potencia la derivada de esta función es
el prima de x sería igual a 4 por x al
cubo y yo creo que están comenzando a
notar el patrón de aquí aunque bueno
aquí no tengo espacio para escribir
arribita algo vamos a ver lo escribo
chiquito efe de aquí si es igual a equis
pues bueno su f prima o su pendiente en
este caso
prima de x va a ser igual a 1 efe prima
de x igual a 1 y creo que alta pueden
adivinar cuál va a ser la siguiente
función x a la quinta su derivada f
prima de x cual quieren que sea muy bien
5 x x a la cuarta
así que podemos generalizar que para
cualquier función que tiene x ^ n como
potencia
fx igual
hay esta pluma en lo que se iguala x
elevado a la m
que después de ser n cualquier exponente
su f primera x va a ser igual a esa m es
el número n x x elevado a ese número
menos 1 como podemos ver acá hay esta
pluma menos 1
así que si él me fuera por ejemplo un 25
x elevado a la potencia de 25 su
derivada sería 25 por equis a la 24 y
ahora voy a usar esta regla y les
mostraré algunas otras para que podamos
encontrar la derivada de cualquier
función polinomio
vamos a quitar esto y aquí les voy a dar
otro par de reglas y es posible que sea
bastante intuitivo para ustedes esta
regla y si sabemos la definición del
límite de la derivada podríamos
demostrarlo si yo tuviera si yo quisiera
encontrar la derivada digamos d
ok estoy escribiendo en otro lugar si
quisiera la derivada
esta anotación quiere decir que cuál es
el cambio con respecto a x
/ de x es otra manera de expresar la
derivada si yo quisiera encontrar la
derivada de a la derivada de a por fx
a es una constante ese sería lo mismo
que decir qué
multiplicado por la derivada con
respecto a x
de fx
y esto que nos dice bueno esto nos dice
que si yo tuviera una f x igual
y bueno esto sólo funciona con
constantes
si me fx fuera igual a 5 x al cuadrado
es lo mismo que decir que 5 x x al
cuadrado sé que estoy diciendo lo obvio
pero tengan paciencia podemos decir que
la derivada de esto es 5 por la derivada
de x cuadrado
efe prima de x es igual a 5 por cual es
la derivada de esto a pues es 2 por x
así que esto es igual a 10 por x
si yo tuviera una gtx
que es igual y mi pluma sigue sin
funcionar bien disculpen
es igual a
3x a la 12
entonces que prima de x
la derivada de g va a ser igual a 3
x la derivada de esto que es 12 x x a la
adiós esta pluma a la 11
por lo que esto es igual a 36 por equis
a la 11 esto es bastante directo
simplemente multiplicamos esto por la
derivada de esta x elevada a una
potencia y ahora quiero agregar otra
cosa más si yo quisiera aplicar el
operador derivada ahí espero que estas
plumas ya no me sigue dando tanta lata
voy a cambiar de color para variar un
poco quiero aplicar mi operador derivada
y vamos a llamar a esto la regla de la
adición o de la suma
fx más
je x
y todo esto es lo mismo que si yo digo
la derivada con respecto a x de fx
más la derivada con respecto a x deje de
x
quizás parece un poco obvio pero quiero
dejar claro estas reglas porque las
vamos a usar más adelante y en un
momento haré un par de ejemplos para que
quede bien entendido y simplemente para
recordar ambas notaciones puedes decir
que todo esto de aquí arriba es
exactamente lo mismo que f de prima de x
y prima
x hay esta pluma de x vamos a hacer un
ejemplo concreto para que quede todavía
más claro digamos que tengo una f x que
es igual
a 3 x x al cuadrado más
5 x x
si quisiéramos encontrar la derivada de
este polinomio efe prima de x tendríamos
que encontrar la derivada de cada uno de
estos términos esto es 3 por 2
6x tomamos el 2 del exponente lo
multiplicamos por esta constante y
reducimos la potencia en 1 así que nos
queda 6x a la 1 que es lo mismo que 6x
más la derivada de 5 x 5 sabemos esto
porque es tuviéramos una línea que fuera
5x pues su pendiente su derivada sería 5
más la derivada de una constante cual es
la derivada de una constante bueno les
doy una pista graphic en una constante
calcula en su pendiente y encontrarán
que está pendiente es cero así que esto
nos va a quedar
pero quizás después lo gráfica para que
quede más claro esto lo ignoramos y nos
queda que es 6 x + 5 es la derivada de
esta otra función y vamos a hacer otro
ejemplo para que quede aún más claro
vamos a decir que tenemos nuestra
función
y vamos a estar cambiando o combinando
las notaciones para que ustedes se
acostumbren a usar cualquiera
tenemos que ya es igual a 10 por equis a
la quinta potencia menos 7 al cubo más
4x más 1
y aquí vamos a aplicar el operador
derivada
decimos que esto es
y
la derivada de y con respecto a x que
recordemos que esto se refiere a cambios
muy muy muy muy pequeños es una de alta
muy pequeña y esto es igual
a 10 por 5 es 50
50 x x a la cuarta menos
7 por 3 21 x al cuadrado más
pero recordamos esto es una constante la
derivada de una constante siempre va a
ser cero y como ven la derivada de este
polinomio ha sido bastante directa y de
hecho son de las más directas en
comparación de otros conceptos que
ustedes han visto en álgebra esto es
todo el tiempo que tengo pero en el
siguiente par de vídeos veremos aún más
reglas para poder resolver derivadas más
complicadas que éstas nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo